Whilst we could roll our own solution for input by polling for keys every frame, Unreal
provides a fantastic and flexible way of adding inputs to our game with full keyboard, mouse,
controller, joystick, touch and VR support.
Unreal supports two systems when it comes to handling input.
There's the old, what we're going to call legacy input support that is rooted
heavily in Unreal 4.
And then there's the newer, more flexible and feature-rich enhanced input.
The legacy system offers a system that can handle hardware inputs, be it from keyboard
and mouse, console controllers and touch controls.
Specialised input devices that don't conform to the aforementioned inputs can also be handled
through the raw input plugin.
The player input is a U object that resides within the player controller, and it's tasked
with managing the player's input.
It's also important to note that this object is only spawned on the client, so we have
no server-side input.
Within Unreal, we can make use of two modes of input binding.
The first is an action mapping.
These will map a button or key pressed to a friendly name that will later be bound to
gameplay behaviours.
This is not polled, rather the gameplay behaviour linked to this mapping will fire
when the button in question is pressed or released.
Secondly, we've got axis mappings.
These will map a button or key pressed to a friendly name that will later be bound to
a continuous gameplay behaviour, such as player movement.
These mappings are polled continuously, even when they're not being pressed, in which case
they're going to return a value of zero.
Input mapping can be done both in native, as we can see at the top of the slide, or
in the Unreal Engine editor, as we can see at the bottom of the slide.
Whilst within the editor, we can access the input binding mappings through the project
settings menu.
Under the engine menu header on the left, we can select input, which will then take
us to the window that we can see at the bottom of this slide.
Input binding in Unreal is simple and can be done in both native C++ and blueprint,
giving developers flexibility in how they implement this functionality.
Next we can look at a simple native C++ implementation of binding to our input in our gameplay code.
As we can see in the first image, we simply override the setupPlayerInputComponent function,
which passes through the input component for the character in this example.
To bind an action, we simply feed through the action name, in our case jump, and
then how we want to react to this event either on the key pressed or on the key released.
Next we pass through the object that the function will be called on, and then lastly
we pass through a function pointer that will be called directly.
For an axis binding, again we feed through an action name, in our case moveForward.
Then we pass through the object that we want to call this function on, and lastly the
function pointer.
Because an axis binding is continuously polled, we don't need to pass through a pressed
or released parameter, it's going to be polled regardless.
And now for the blueprint implementation, and as we can see, it is much much more simple.
Having created our input mappings as shown on the previous slide, Unreal will create
handy InputAxis and InputAction events that match the name of our input mappings.
In the top node, we have our continuously polled axis mapping, which feeds through the
value detected by the input system.
We still need to keep in mind that even though a button is not pressed, it will continue
to feed through a value of 0 to any of these bindings.
We can see on the bottom node that we have our action mappings.
Blueprint allows us to use either the pressed and or released callbacks to bind our gameplay
functionality, as well as feed through the key that was detected.
So now that we know how input mapping and input binding works, we should maybe take
a look at how the actual input is processed under the hood.
The Enhanced Input System is a plugin that makes creating and manipulating inputs easier
by means of making them asset based.
There are two types of asset we need to be familiar with when working with the Enhanced
Input System.
The first is the InputAction, and this defines the concept of a binding.
For example, we might create a new asset called WalkForwards or Jump.
We've not actually linked the idea to a set of keys or modifiers, merely outlined that
walking forwards and jumping is something that we want to be able to do in our game
and bind gameplay functionality to it.
In this sense, we can think of an InputAction as a way of identifying a particular section
of the keyboard bindings later down the line.
The InputContext lets us marry that InputAction to a set of hardware inputs such as keys
to be used in our gameplay code.
The InputAction asset is actually fairly sparse in terms of settings and parameters
for us to play with.
The most important parameter we should look at is the value type where we specify what
kind of data we expect this input to produce.
Digital is a 0 or a 1, ideal for fire and forget actions such as jumping.
Axis 1 is ideal for strength based inputs like move forwards.
Axis 2 is good for bi-directional inputs such as thumbstick input, assessing both X
and Y at the same time.
Axis 3 is good for things like spatial movements or inputs that take into account
a vertical movement like VR input.
As mentioned earlier in this topic, an InputContext gives us a method of linking input actions
to keys and behaviors.
In terms of actual setup, we can see we simply choose what input action we want to
add to our context before defining what hardware inputs we want to link to it.
You can also see that we have an array of modifiers per key, and this is fantastically
useful when dealing with things like dead zones.
We can simply add a dead zone modifier to our thumbstick binding, and Unreal will
handle filtering out the dead zone input for us, so no need to build in any additional
functionality to our code to handle these errant cases.
Of course, we're free to author our own modifiers to complement the ones that come
out of the box.
Binding to an enhanced input is similar to our legacy bindings but with a couple more
steps.
Firstly, we need to push our context, and this is our opportunity to source the correct
context for our current circumstances.
Do we need the swimming context, or the walking context, or even the driving a car
context?
We simply add the context that we need.
And of course, we're free to clear all mappings as shown above.
Lastly, we need to bind our actions.
In this case, InputMove is an input action we've defined alongside our contexts.
You'll notice that the IE pressed and IE released enums have been replaced with an
E-trigger event enum, covering an extended spread of input cases.
We can now support triggered, started, ongoing, cancelled, and completed as trigger types.
Input components are present on all actors, but are most commonly seen inside pawns and
player controllers.
They can be added to level script actors as well, as the level is, after all, an
actor in its own right.
The input component links the input mappings that we've just made to the actions that
we wish to see in our game, and this can be done both in native or in Blueprint.
Input processing in Unreal works from a stack.
The priority stack for input handling can be seen here.
Firstly, it handles any actors that have except input enabled, from the most recently
enabled to the least recently enabled.
Controllers are handled next, followed by the level blueprint, and lastly, we deal
with pawns.
If one input component consumes the input, then the input is not available further down
the input stack.
As a general tip, if you wish for a particular actor to always be considered ahead of the
others, re-enabling its except input will move it to the top of this stack.
Lastly, for projects that require more complex input features like complex input handling
or runtime control remapping, the enhanced input plugin implements such features as
radial dead zones, chorded actions, contextual input and prioritization, and finally it will
extend the bespoke filtering and processing of raw input data in an asset-based environment.
Let's talk about delegates and events.
Unreal provides a full suite of delegates and event macros for us to leverage into
performant sensibly structured code architectures, eliminating the need for constant condition
polling.
So let's take a look at what delegates are in Unreal and how we can go about declaring them.
So quick recap, what is a delegate?
A delegate is a data type that can reference and execute member functions on C++ objects
in a generic and type safe way.
Delegates can be bound dynamically to a member function of an object to call that
object in the future.
Delegates are safe to copy and can be passed around by value, however this process
will allocate memory on the heap, so instead it's highly recommended that you pass delegates
by reference whenever possible.
So let's take a look at what types of delegates Unreal actually offers.
The Unreal Engine offers the following types of delegates.
Firstly we have single delegates, and this is a one-to-one binding, and they can
be saved and loaded.
Next are multicast delegates, and this is a one-to-many binding, and these delegates
can be bound by both reflection types and raw lambdas.
It's important to note that multicast delegates cannot use return values.
Next we have dynamic delegates, and these again are a one-to-many binding, however these
delegates can only be bound by reflection types and are serializable.
It's also important to note that these delegates are slower than regular delegates,
and execution of a dynamic delegate must be paired with an isBound check prior to
calling execute.
Alternatively, we can make use of the executeIfBound function, which will both check if it
is bound and then execute for us.
Lastly we have events.
Events offer the same functionality as a multicast delegate.
However the broadcast functionality is retained exclusively by the class that declares the event.
Derived classes of the base class which declared this event in the first place do
not inherit access to that broadcast.
If a derived class wishes to make use of that functionality, then the base class
must expose some kind of protected function that will fire the broadcast for them.
Lastly we do have abstract events which can be inherited by derived classes, but we'll
explain more about those in the next few slides.
Unreal offers a wide range of macros that can be used to declare a delegate or event.
Each macro features parameters for your new delegate, as well as the function's return
type, however the declaration of this delegate differs from types that should simply
return void.
Delegate macros support the following combinations.
We have functions that return a value, functions that are declared as const, and
then we have up to four payload variables as well as eight function parameters.
To declare a delegate, we simply use the corresponding macro for our particular technical
design.
For example, in the top image we declare a dynamic multicast delegate that passes through
a float payload to the object that is bound to it.
And as you may have noticed, this example is accompanied by the uDelegate macro.
Delegate functions support the same specifiers as u functions, but you need to use the
uDelegate macro instead.
In the second example, we declare an event that is owned by the adventure component
and passes through a float payload to the object binding to it.
In the third example, we declare a delegate that returns a float and passes through an
f-string payload to the object that is bound to it.
Lastly, in the last two images, we can see the declaration of an abstract event in the
inventory interface.
This event passes through a float payload to the object that is bound to it, and then
in a derived class, in this case an inventory component, we declare a derived event that
is owned by the component instead, and thus can be fired by it.